You're the time limiting factor. You go
as far back as you want. Okay. All
right. Uh just because people may be
amazed at what even children can do. I
was 6 and a half year. Just to let
people know, I was born in Kuwait 1972
Kuwaiti. But I'm Assyrian Asharaya. So I
people may think, oh, I was Arab. No,
it's never like even Coptics, they're
not Arabic, they're African, you guys.
So I came to Chicago with my Assyrian
parents in 1974. So I was not raised in
the Middle East. I have no idea about
the Middle East. Don't know Arabic.
People may think I know Arabic. No, I
speak Ashuri. So I can speak Assyrian,
but I speak a particular dialect, Jiru.
So my parents cultural Christian because
you well know Church of the East called
Nistorians. Sadly all the schism that
goes with it. But they never told me
about Christianity. Never told me about
Jesus Christ. I just remember going to
the church maybe once every Sunday
and you know on the big days as a child.
So never talked to me about
Christianity. My parents never told me
about Jesus or how to pray. Now here's
where God can use children. In the
neighborhood there was a nine-year-old
Assyrian from Lebanon. His name was
Raymond Melco. His grandmother is
maternal
grandmother on his mother's side and
raised him because sadly his mother died
when he was several years old. So she
raised him
his uncles. So the grandmother was
Catholic. His uncles became Baptists.
This is on his mother's side. So his
mother's brothers. So he was a mixture
of Catholicism and Baptist theology. So
if your audience are not familiar with
Baptists, they love to go doortodoor and
do what's called the Romans road to
salvation. Meaning if you belong to what
we call in the west independent
fundamental Baptist denomination, part
of their ministry is go doortodoor,
knock on doors and get people saved.
So this was his influence because his
uncles were taught that theology. So,
it's called the sinner's road to, you
know, the road sinner's road to
salvation. So, you tell them you're a
sinner. Jesus died for you. They show
you some verses and go pray this prayer
and then you're saved. So, a
nine-year-old boy being trained this way
eyed me. He came up to me and started
talking about Jesus Christ. I had no
idea who Jesus was, you know. And even
when I think about my testimony,
sometimes I get really emotional. So, if
you see me trying to hold back, it's
amazing.
I'm sorry.
Take your time. It's a beautiful thing.
I don't know why it hits me, but it hits
me sometimes. Nine-year-old boy and he
told me, "Jesus Christ is the son of God
who loved you so much to die for you."
And I was floored at six and a half. Was
it six and a half? I was amazed, sorry,
that uh someone could love me this much.
I didn't expect to cry, but the
testimony moves me. So he told me, now I
was young and impressionable. So
whatever he told me, I took literally.
He said, "Go say this prayer at night."
So I took him literally. I had to say it
at night because that's when Jesus is
going to hear me. You know, you're a
kid. You don't know.
I knew I was going to forget those words
because I thought it's, you know, I have
to say it that way. He's telling me what
he learned and I'm taking him literally.
And I knew by the time night came, I was
going to forget those words. So I kept
repeating it. kept repeating it. Night
came and I forgot the words. But I do
remember at night cuz I used to be
scared to sleep by myself. So sometimes
I'd sleep next to my mother. And I
remember at 6 and a half and tears
asking Jesus
to enter my life. I don't know how to
invite you in,
but I want you in my life. So that's my
journey. Now he he would teach me how to
go and evangelize. He was 9 years old.
He used to preach in the streets. There
are people from Chicago that remember
that. Even now they remember him at 9 in
Chicago, north side of Chicago. People
are from Chicago listening, they'll know
it's on Clark Street, Foster Avenue,
Andersonville. So if there's anyone
listening, you know I'm talking about
that area. I would follow him and he'd
preach and crowds would gather because
they're shocked. a nine-year-old boy
preaching. Wow. No. And the Lord is my
witness if I'm like their witness is
still alive. Don't remember. Incredible.
Years later, he had to move, relocate. I
became a teenager and I did what
teenagers do. I didn't have a
foundation. He was my foundation as a
child because my parents didn't tell me
Christianity. So, I started doing what
teenagers do sadly. you know, I'm not
going to glorify it, but you know, going
out late, getting drunk, smoking
cigarettes, etc. So, fast forward,
I had very low self-esteem and I wanted
love and affirmation, so I got into
bodybuilding. I know you can't tell
that, father.
You can't tell. We'll arm wrestle one
day and we'll see. I'm not going to be
the one that disagrees here. I'm the one
to talk. Only on the buffet table. I'll
arm wrestle you for that slice of pizza.
I'll win that one. I can guarantee that.
So I I thought maybe if I get into
bodybuilding and Bruce Lee, as you guys
if everyone watches me, man, I watched
Bruce Lee and he became my idol. I fell
in love with Bruce Lee. So I said, you
know what? I'm going to get into
kickboxing. I'm going to be a
bodybuilder and become the first
Assyrian superstar.
Okay. So I was really delusional. So at
one time I had a V-shaper. Now I have an
upside down V. But you know, so
but the more I trained, the more
miserable I became. So now I'm around 17
years old. I realized, man, I need God.
But for some reason, I didn't want to
have anything to do with Jesus anymore.
Things had happened to me in my
childhood. My dad had left my family. My
uncle, who was very close to me, died of
cancer. He was around in his 40s. So I
guess I got upset at Jesus cuz he was
the one I knew as a kid. So I blamed him
and so I didn't really think much about
Jesus but I knew I needed God. Now this
is how Satan works. This is so advice
for the youth. When you are looking for
God, Satan knows that and he will give
you religion as long as not the true
religion. So people don't realize this.
Satan doesn't care if you're religious
religious. He created all these
religions. He just doesn't want you to
find the true faith. So be a Buddhist,
be a Hindu, be a Muslim. That's okay.
just don't come to the true faith, the
true Christ and the true church because
that's when you escape his snares. So
Satan saying that I want to know God, he
placed in my path. Now remember, I don't
know this at this time. I'm learning
this as we go along. He placed in my
path a member of the Nation of Islam. Oh
boy. Okay. So you a lot of people don't
know the Nation of Islam anymore because
I'm kind of old. Nation of what? But you
know the Nation of Islam? Definitely.
Father Gabri, you know about the Nation
of Islam?
No, I don't. See, you're much younger
than I thought. You're scaring me. All
right. Nation of Islam. You know, the
most famous spokesperson for that
movement was Malcolm X. Mhm. Really? Oh,
yeah. He's the one who made it. He
converted. He became a nation. Now,
Nation Islam is not traditional Islam.
Just a real briefly, it was started by a
man named Elijah P, who changed his name
to Elijah Kharim, who then changed his
name to Elijah Muhammad. It's a pro
black movement. It's all about black. In
fact, Nation Islam says Allah was a
black man.
The first people are black people. So
this is why blacks were drawn to it. So
now this gentleman that I was witnessing
to, he was black. So he's part of the
Nation of Islam. Now in the late 80s,
early 90s, the leader, and he's still
alive from what I know, I don't think
he's passed away, is Minister Lewis
Farrakhan.
His name is Louisis Farrakhan. One of
the most powerful orators you'll ever
meet. He can captivate you. He'll speak
for hours without notes. Quoting the
Bible Quran from memory. Amazing speaker
but a deceiver because to them Allah is
a black man. And then their founder
Elijah Muhammad was a prophet. And the
black man needs Elijah Muhammad and
their version of Islam. So I have no
idea about Islam. I have no idea about
Prophet Muhammad because he kept
mentioning Prophet Muhammad. Then he
mentioned Elijah Muhammad. Then he
mentioned master Farat Muhammad. Now not
to confuse your audience. I'm learning
this later on. Now I understand what he
meant. We know who Muhammad is, the
father of Islam. So they believe in him
but then they believe in a man named
Wallace Ford who appeared as a white man
but in reality his name was Master Farad
Muhammad and he was actually Allah
appearing in the likeness of sinful
flesh. Now notice how they perverted
Romans 8:3. Romans chapter 8:3 where are
told that God sent his forth his son in
the likeness of sinful flesh.
That's Romans 8:3. Now, what does that
mean? It means that though Christ is
flesh, he wasn't sinful. Though he
appeared to be an ordinary human like
you and I. So, in the likeness of sinful
flesh, what Paul means, so just the
audience doesn't get confused means that
we know from scripture, if you're human,
you're a sinner. So, if I see a human
being, oh, that's a sinner. So, when you
saw Jesus and then know he's God, you
think he's another sinner. That's what
Paul means in the likeness of sinful
flesh because he wasn't sinful. But he
was truly human, who had a true human
nature. Anyway, they take that verse to
mean that Wallace Ford, a black man
who's Allah, appeared as a white man
because that's the sinful flesh, being
white.
Because this movement teaches white
people are devils and Jews are devils.
That's what this movement teaches. How
old are you at this point, Sam? I was
born 72, so I would be early 90s. That's
probably my uh in fact even before 90s
because I think it was 90 I was around
18. But even though you're not
African-American, they accept you now at
this point or what? No, no, no. How did
I get curious? I just wanted to give a
little history. Oh, okay. Okay. I want
because I'm I'm assuming people are
going to listen. Very young people. I'm
old enough to be their grandfather.
They're going to have no idea what I'm
talking about. Not true. Right. So, like
what do you mean? Okay. So, I just want
them to know even orthodox Muslims
condemn them. Okay. you. So we know
Sunni Islam will never accept them.
Allah is a black man.
So but in the west in the 60s7s 80s this
move movement was exploding because it
gave black people an identity to feel
proud about themselves. After all God
himself is black.
So this bought into that. You know, when
you have low self-esteem and you're
oppressed and you have a movement that's
centered on skin color and making you
the greatest, like even your god is
black. You see why people are drawn to
it from that culture. Mhm. Now, the
reason why
this got me interested is because the
man that was member of Nation of Islam,
his name was
he kept saying, "Praise be to Almighty
Allah." Praise be to Almighty Allah.
Now, I'm very baffled because he's not
Assyrian. Why is he using the word
Allah? Because as an Assyrian, we say
Allah, right? For those who speak
Assyrian calian, we say Allah. So he's
saying Allah and that got me curious. So
I asked him, I said, I want to ask you a
question. How do you know this word
Allah? That's when he started preaching
his spiel and he talked about the Holy
Quran. So I said, "Do you have a copy?
Can you get me?" He got me a copy and I
was flabbergasted. Now I want your
audience to understand my parents came
from the Middle East, but they never, as
far as I can recall, mentioned Muslims
to me. M they did not teach me anything
about Christianity. Nor did they mention
about Islam. So if you're not educating
your children at home, someone will
educate them. Mhm. I received my
education about Islam from this guy who
then gave me a Quran. And as I reading
the Quran, I'm blown away to find
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob. So I went to
the back where they have an index where
you can find they'll say Jesus and where
to find. So I read everything about
Jesus and I'm baffled because I did not
know there's another book that mentions
Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob or Moses or
Jesus. So what did that did was put a
fire in my heart to go back to the
Bible. Why? is remember of my
upbringing. That nine-year-old boy being
from a Baptist background and a Catholic
background who had a Bible in his hand
and his uncles who preached the Bible
and on top of that there was a bus
ministry
in Hammond, Indiana. The church is still
there today. So I want people to fact
check me so don't think I'm
exaggerating. It's called First Baptist
Church of Hammond Indiana. In the 70s
they would sign up bus routes, pick up
kids and take them to this huge church.
So I used to go every Sunday. So I got
indoctrinated in Baptist theology and a
high view of the Bible. Right. So you
actually had knowledge about the Bible
at this point in time when you I knew
about the Bible but I was no scholar of
it. I mean as a kid I would read it but
I didn't understand. So I knew about the
Bible. Okay. So this was the foundation
of what God is using because I was
taught from that age this is the word of
God. So later on, what did I do? Let me
go check the word of God. Mhm. So as I
started reading the New Testament, I
fell in love with Jesus over all over
again.
I remember the night. See, I think you
guys set me up so I can start crying
like a baby. That's what you guys You're
taking time here. Yeah. Know the story
is very emotional for me because I can
bear witness. I have failed Jesus and
sadly I failed Jesus. But I can bear
witness. He has never ever failed me and
he's never hurt me and he's never
abandoned me. Amen. I think we can all
say we failed Jesus, but he never fails
us. Says, but I mean what what he what
he did in orchestrating events in my
life.
I have no doubt that he's in love with
me. My prayer is I can't be in love with
him. But I remember that night as I
started reading the New Testament, I
fell on my knees in tears and I said,
"Jesus,
I'm back home again."
Just with your Bible in your hand. Yeah.
I'm back home. I've come home again.
Prod your prodical son has come home. I
knew about that story. But anyway, I
still had a hard time with Muhammad
though because I was reading a sanitized
version about Muhammad. you know, he's
this great man and he suffered
persecution. So, I really struggled how
do I reconcile Muhammad's sincerity with
the New Testament because I could see
their glaring contradictions. So, I
think for about two years, I really
struggled with letting go of Muhammad
because I thought he was sincere until
the Lord gave me a breakthrough. The
breakthrough came where I was reading
throughout the New Testament and I
realized Satan appears as an angel of
light. For those who want to know where
that is, that's in 2 Corinthians chapter
11:14. In the context of false apostles,
Paul, if you read 2 Corinthians 11, he's
warning about false apostles. He says,
"I'll preach another Jesus from the one
we preached, a different gospel from the
one we received, and different spirit."
And he says that Satan's ministers,
these false apostles, appear as
ministers of righteousness. And then he
says, "No wonder, for Satan himself
appears as an angel of light,
masquerades as an angel of light." So
that's when the light switch went on.
Pun intended. Second 11 14. Oh, Muhammad
was visiting. So then I was finally
freed from Muhammad. Now, how'd I get
into apologetics? That's a different
story.